together we sail her doilies and her
awful children to you there's no excuse
hi there it's kevin van ORD standing in
for reviewer Cameron Woolsey to bring
you the video review for wayward Manor
in wayward manor it's your job as a
mansions poltergeist to scare the
residents away this is a modest puzzle
game featuring play of good-natured
charm and slapstick humor but you're not
the only one haunting the manors
creaking halls an array of game ending
glitches are more frightening than any
of the scares at your disposal and a
lack of challenge turns the second half
into a snooze the key vanished into the
yawning da beyond my sight I was
reminded of the cleaning I truly
required as the manors sole guardian you
must move from room to room scaring away
unwanted guests you approach this goal
by manipulating certain objects in a
room marked with an eerie spectral glow
using your paranormal abilities you pray
upon the family's anxieties or frighten
them with tactful snares including mouse
traps and a pirate ghost that slashes at
them from a painting you can rattle a
stone bust which grabs the victims
attention long enough for you to send a
bottle flying toward her head you can
have a rat scurry across the path of the
family made causing her to jump a
successful scare rewards you with a
green skull and the more skulls you earn
the stronger your presence in a room
allowing you to manipulate even more
objects as you frighten the pants off
various intruders once you collect six
skulls you activate a ghastly whirlwind
that whips up loose objects sending your
hapless victims screaming out the door
for good
do-do-do-do tired
at first there's a sense of discovery in
solving wayward manners puzzles but the
excitement dissipates quickly by the
time you hit the third chapter a cursory
glance is all that's required to figure
out each levels mystery gameplay
stagnates and there are only so many
times you can whack one of the dopey
characters on the head with a bottle
before boredom seeps in as you enter the
game's third chapter the lack of variety
turns puzzle solving into more of a
mechanical motion if you do find
yourself at a loss creatures such as
cats birds and gargoyles offer advice on
how to approach the puzzle narration is
spoken in a storybook style and the game
fully embraces its peculiar art the
multi storied Manor is warped and
cartoonish yet still McCobb the family
inhabiting the manor is made up of
diminutive caricatures exhibiting
charming mannerisms and their voices are
replaced by the sounds of various
musical instruments unfortunately
wayward manners most memorable
attributes are its bugs and game ending
glitches the most innocent of the issues
include the whirlwind which forces
objects to clip through walls and people
and some occasional animation foibles
such as characters sprinting backward
among the worst however is the
surprisingly frequent gameplay bug that
causes the puzzle and characters to
freeze the final level is especially
irritating because a necessary puzzle
piece might refuse to click into place
wayward manor with its brevity and
elementary one-button approach to
gameplay is not a complicated game it's
unfortunate that the number of bugs
infesting it make things so problematic
and frustrating the game spooky ambience
is enjoyable but not enough to
overshadow the humdrum puzzle solving
nor to distract you from the glitches
otay